Hey, I'm getting I'm getting like pulled into I'm getting pulled
into drama, Jerry, that I'm not a part of. Like 10 of them all
joined at once and my own mod was running over to tell Queman
and Jtock I timed them out. Hellbent didn't say anything. Hellbent
talked to Why am I included here? Hellbent didn't talk to me.
Hellbent was not my chat. Queman told me that this happened like
hours earlier. Leave me out of your problems with Quimman, Nicholas.
Your problems are with Quean. Stop trying to attack me. I'm not
involved. Actually, I'm literally not involved at all. My editor
doesn't like you. I can't help that. Okay. It's saying Dioro
is manually timing out people mentioning Coan and Chud in his
chat. Not Not a great look. Or why is Hellbent leaking? That's
not very nice, is it?
Hellbent to say he manually timing them out. Well, how would
anyone know which moderator is timing out people in his chat?
Hellbent. How would someone in public know who's doing that?
It sounds like you know that cuz you're a moderator. Yeah. Hel
140 IQ helmet here fellas. Okay. Crazy stuff happening
here. Screw you guys.
You know why this is as well, dude? This is like my This isn't
even my fault, but it's like going to get blamed on me. This
stupid [__] Elbent, who's a [__] mod
in Dioro's chat, comes into my chat and says, "Oh, you know,
Nick Dioro is timing out everyone manually who mentions your
ch." He's manually timing out every single person who mentions
your ch. She says that in my chat and then lo and behold, chat
fills up with debate. Debate queen, debate queen, debate queen.
It's like,
oh my god, you guys are [__] You are actually such
a silly [__] It's crazy.
But I'm not involved. I'm not fighting you. I'm not going after
you. Okay, fight. Hit Que. Okay, go after that guy. Stop. I'm
not involved. Get Go away from me. Stop using my name. No, don't
hurt
Just stay away. Stay away from
Well, I'm I'm just saying that like he wants to he wants to start
a fight with me instead of fight with the actual person who's
[__] with you. It's not me. No, I'm just kidding.
I I That is what I want.